celebra questa festa è questa
[Musica]
i sanitari sono oggi vorrei una
challenge epica e cioè lo slime
telepatico io contro il mio cagnolino
merlino vediamo separano le stesse
scelte vediamo alla fine se il mio plans
tra molto diverso da quello che ha
scelto merlino non super curiosa di
vedere poiché colore sceglierà un
berlino perché oggi abbiamo delle colle
vezzali esercita un certo per prima il
vero chi temo però che succede ora le
cose speciali che abbiamo oggi sono le
nuove colle della skifidol raschi ficola
tv dawn glitter che potete trovare in
edicola
e fantastico che hanno creato la loro
colla per slime perché sapete che è
sempre complicato trovare la colla che
funziona per lo slime è facilissimo
perché basta andare in edicola e la
trovate subito in più ha già i glitter
dentro quindi è fantastico con questo
potete fare lo slime ed esce al cento
per cento in più è anche lavabile quindi
cento per cento sicure a stelo 7 coloro
ne assume e curiosa di vedere come
usciranno l'islam con queste colle
glitterate e sono curioso di vedere come
saranno diverse le mie scelte con quelle
di merlino o trovare laschi ficola
schifino in edicola in allegato alla
rivista a 3 euro e 50 che oggi ci sono
nel video lo farò solo da assistente a
berlino quindi che sceglierà e io
metterò solo le colle dentro dentro la
ciotola per noi l'anti però però
è una slide di berlino ora primo round
dovremo scegliere fra la college elette
la colla rotta il brutto meglio prima io
e poi voi vedrete quale si gira berlino
io non vedo
allora io scelgo che berlino che sa
quale seminari grazie
la scelta simile scelta ok ora mettiamo
la nostra prima schifi con la skifidol
nella ciotola chissà se abbiamo senso la
stessa perché io lì non sta controllando
che stia facendo tutto come controllato
se stai mettendo la colla che esse il
thun e fumi una super glitterato che
bello a parte il colore che stupendo non
posso dire quale è già però i glitter
sono fantastici non vedo l'ora di
vederla attiva
wow che è come la mia prima scelta
chissà se abbiamo scelto uguale il
coroner tantissimo ora dobbiamo notte
con di assen
allora seconda scelta per la seconda
scelta abbiamo il verde e qui non dico
niente
anche noi abbiamo il giallo si fingono
problema perché gialloverde
ma io non posso dire che cosa
ho scelto però
però anche rosso e verde diventa infatti
e ne sento un po difficile questa
commenta questa volta a segno prima
merlino quali scelti partito con accenni
di questo questo direi che ha scelto ha
fatto la sua scelta ha fatto la sua
scelta
ciao a tutti chiusi e non vi spaventate
serve anche la boccuccia il primo tanto
seguente le promuove allora visto scelto
si è sicuro si ok ho fatto anch'io la
mia scelta
poi vogliamo ora mettere 100 chiesto ai
102 così si mangiava lancio lancio e
vendola dietro visto gli sta tenendo la
palla perché si vuole buttare tutti gli
svizzeri tutto e tutto la colla bild che
io vado già mettere la mia colla sono
proprio curioso di vedere cosa mi
metterò a quella che ha scelto merlino
[Musica]
brutto con sentimento asi anche youtube
come anche tu mi sa che berlino ha fatto
fatto una scelta un po discutibile
diciamo devo dire niente e merlino che
ha scelto ok ok di rete wow
questi amori dovuto fare un'altra scelta
ok diciamo che berlino ha un ottimo
gusto
ok prossima scelta ed round numero 36 di
questa scelta abbiamo la city con la
rosa la mamma e la ski ficola arancio
[Musica]
ovviamente tutte hanno i glitter venuta
per un cartello stavolta è vero allora
io scelgo 6 e certo è qui che il di
averli le cose serie
alle celle marino ha scelto direi
proprio di sì la prima buttato a terra e
stesso cercando di mangiarselo sotto
quello di sicuro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
cosa è vedere come cambia il colore vado
a mettere la biocom vedo l'ora di vedere
lo slime attivato quello di merlino per
vedere quanto è simile al mio di amore
di che colore diventa marley non mi è
sembrato molto soddisfatto passività e
un particolare colore che piace al
mattino ti parlo dei primati notturno
preferì ultimo turno abbiamo la colla
viola e poi abbiamo il resto delle colle
che non abbiamo scelto deciderà berlino
non meno ma di scegliere tra segni prima
berlin questa questa la somma che
prendermi a casa del migliore per opel e
scegli per questa festa questa festa ma
glielo posso indicare freddi
io direi proprio che si è appuntato
questa fin dall'inizio che allora ora se
li ion molla molla alla mamma mia
ok abbiamo la scelta di marino ok ora
andiamo a mettere la nostra ultima col
berlino questa volta lo sta controllando
si è steso della strumento per tema
perché era stanco detto si scusa con
tutti voi però doveva fare il suo
riposino
ok ora possiamo postare all'ultimo turno
tra le ditte ora ultimo round per
l'ultimo round bevuto istituti giungere
dei glitter così diventa ancora più
glitterato e andiamo bitter blu
poi abbiamo glitter celeste detto che
abbiamo twitter viola allora serve prima
in cui sei ok sono indizi da questa
volta io con questo che ha scelto marino
una mezza idea di quale starebbe meglio
però deve scegliere lui allora io ho
scelto questo vediamo quale seggi e
berline merlino sei pronto siamo pronti
con i scesi di berlino ok ha scelto era
quello che volevo consigliere io quasi
recenti ma con l'animale che poiché non
mettere la rimastri glitter e poi
mettevo a trovarlo è vedere se simile o
no è servito berlino oppure lo ammette
glitter diamo un iniziale ancora più
bello devo dire che mi ha scelto bene
questa volta possiamo procedere ad
attivarli sì ma non dobbiamo vedere lo
slime dell'altra persona affinché non è
attivo e naturalisti quale voto nella
cuccia si parlino così lotti vi amo li
amo te ma guardare
ok praticarlo basta mettere un pò
archivio di bicarbonato di sodio a mio
nome perché apple e donne stanche la
soluzione per lenti felicissimo da
attivare cerco di mettere pu soluzione
per l'ente pochissimo stavano per niente
tutto un po di e credo che un po di
bicarbonato maestà vari crateri che il
bicarbonato non ne va messo troppo
ricordate glielo vitale che non va messo
tanto bicarbonato di berlino che i
ragazzi ci siamo il nostro slime è
attivo qui fi
siamo pronti alla rivelazione sono
pregate di vedere se sarà uguale o se
sarà completamente diverso pronti siamo
ora
[Musica]
ma certo non sarebbe stato mai se
preferite chiamato valigie volte siamo a
berlino invece una sorta di bertolino
chiaro albergo di noventa un po
celestino è il patrono e tantissimi
glitter super estendibile felice questa
col è stata molto meglio di quello che
prendo in genere è trasparente io sono
riuscito ad attivarlo benissimo e che
bisogna un cattivo è sempre troppo duro
e anzi per caso dopo anche un sacco di
un sacco di bicarbonato da questa volta
invece attento bellissimo derby diavoli
più da vicino così potete anche votare
se vinco io se vince berlino fra il mio
slime allora come potete vedere il
colore è una sorta di celestino
verdolino grigino è un galaxy diciamo
quindi l'inter a tutti gli interni alla
fine può prenderli per viola e tu
anch'io a pezzi anche motivo oggi ever
berlino ha scelto allora la consistenza
è fantastica e veramente morbido
nonostante non abbia aggiunto niente né
l'opzione schiuma da barba niente
morbidissimo sentiamo i suoni smr
quindi fa anche un sacco di stone in ore
vendibile e quindi piaciuta questa colla
allora questo è il mio sliven vediamo
ora per la di vitale con un bollino per
di berlino il vero è bello sembra durato
infatti lo abbiamo chiamato l'abbiamo
chiamata gold vaniglia ago barilla super
morbido tom sacco di rumori sentite le
bollicine sono ancora chiariti questi
slime perché sapete che la folla
trasparente dopo un po ballo viene
pulizia e sotto chiariti saranno ancora
più belli ecco qua ottimo suoi
bellissimi sono se barluzzi meno cosi
metallizzati belli glitterati votate chi
vince servizio il mio servizio quello di
berlino
io di berlino anche se mi piace tanto
anche il tuo bellissimi tutti e due
quindi questa col veramente fantastica
mi piace tanto e morbidissima super
allungabile e fa un sacco di rumore snr
davvero la adoro e vi ricordo che lo
potrete trovare in edicola a 350 in
allegato alla rivista skifidol dante nel
sondaggio sei vinco io o se vince lo
slime di marley me sono un po 4
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]